[Music]
bigquery can process enormous amounts of
data
adding cost controls can protect you
from runaway queries whether you have
multiple bigquery projects and users
or it's just you you can manage costs by
setting a custom quota that specifies a
limit on the amount of query data
processed
per day this video will take you through
the process of establishing your own
custom quotas
you may set quotas to control costs at
the project level or
at the user level project level custom
quotas limit the aggregate usage of all
users in that project
while user level custom quotas are
separately applied to each user or
service account within a project
you may use either of these quota
options or both in tandem
used in tandem usage will count against
both quotas and adhere to the stricter
of the two limits
an example scenario can be found at the
documentation linked below
start by navigating to the quotas menu
in the iam
and admin console make sure you have the
right project selected
filter the quotas for the bigquery api
service
check the box for query usage per day
and or query usage per day per user
and click edit quotas set your email
and phone number these contact details
may be used when processing certain
quota requests
enter your daily quotas in tebibytes
notice that the quotas are in tebabytes
so be sure to make any necessary
conversions
click done and then click submit request
review the changes and click confirm
quota changes should take effect within
a few minutes
once the quotas are set if project level
or user level custom quotas are exceeded
bigquery returns an error daily quotas
reset at midnight pacific
time for more information on custom
quotas please visit the documentation
and faqs linked below
happy analyzing
[Music]